Alhamdulillah.
[Silence]
Abdahbdas.
Was forch.
[Silence]
for
continuing in
the chapter regarding sincerity and
intentions.
reports a narration here on the
authority of Abbass
regarding intentions regarding how Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala counts and documents
and rewards for good deeds and good
intentions or bad deeds and bad
intentions.
He mentions here a narration on the
authority of Abbass that the messenger
of Allah
said that Allah himself has said
that Allah has written
the good deeds and the bad deeds and
we'll get to what is meant by written
here in a moment. inshallah he says
and then he explained what is meant by
he has written the good deeds and the
bad deeds and then he went on to
elaborate
he said hence whoever
has the intention to do a good thing and
then does not end up doing it Allah will
write it for him and count it as a full
merit a full hass
and if he has the intention of doing it
and then follows through with doing it,
Allah will write it for him as 10
merits, 10 good deeds, 10
up to 700 times up to many times beyond
that. And if a person holds an intention
to do something bad and then does not do
it, Allah will write it for him as a
full merit.
And if a person has the intention to do
a bad deed and then follows through with
it and does it, Allah will write it as
one bad deed. He will only write it as
one sin. This narration has been
collected by both Bkari and Muslim. Here
he mentions Abbass.
Abbass is Abdullahb Abbass is Kuna
and that's his father's name. Abbes.
And that is a very common practice even
to this day that a son
and particularly the eldest son but in
this case this is not the case would
name his firstborn
son after his father
and would then be referred to as Abul
Abb in this instance his father's name
is Abbass be referred to as Abu Abbass
and he is Ib Abbass. And this is a kind
of honor that young men in the in
those times would honor their fathers
with and it's something that
continues to this day. We mentioned that
a kuna abu something or omu in the case
of a a woman something whatever it is
will come from a number of places. It
could come from a number of things.
could be something that occurred
in this person's life that was
significant we mentioned Abu Bakr
Abu Bakr
when he came down off of the pulley
in the battle of to join the prophet Sam
and a pulley is called a beak in the
Arabic language. though he is referred
to as Abu Bakr or as some scholars have
mentioned with regards to Abu Hurah
is for
and it's a little cat. So it said in in
some
that Abu
was carrying a a small kitten in his
sleeve, a sleeve of one of his cloaks
and the prophet sallallah.aii wasallam
saw this and he said what is that? He
said this is my kitten and he said
you are to be known as Abu then and
so forth also Abu Tab for Ali
and so forth. there's also which
is the most common that a person will
get his kuna from his children's names.
So usually the eldest son this is where
they get their kuna from person has
three kids you know let's say
you know
khalif and abdman and and hud right so
the oldest son
this is the one that the person would
get their ka from so it' be abd for
instance This is not necessarily a
set rule. There are cases when a person
will be named
with his kuna or called with his kuna
not the eldest of his son but any one of
the other of his kids.
Or it's it's also possible or known that
person may have a daughter that he
will then get his kuna from. It's very
it's much more rare but it does happen
and we have instances of that amongst
the companions. So Iban Abbah
he gets his from
his
father his father's name is Albb is the
prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam's
uncle and he is referred to as Abbdahb
Abbi
the prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam
has four uncles. When we say uncles,
we're speaking about paternal uncles.
Two of them were disbelievers and two of
them were believers.
The two believers were Hamza
and Albbah,
one of which is considered more virtuous
than the other. and two disbelieving
uncles. They were Abu Lahab and Abu
Talib
and one of them is considered worse than
the other and that is Abuahab
and so Abdullahb Abbass
was the prophet sallall.aii alaihi
wasallam's paternal
uncle. Paternal uncle. So he's excuse
me, paternal cousin. So he is his
cousin from his
father's side.
He was born
3 years before hijra.
So this would place him in about the
10th year after prophethood.
And that would also mean that he was
born in a in
whenish
got together and decided to cut off and
excommunicate the prophet sallall.aii
wasallam and anyone affiliated with him
and his entire tribe.
They went to the of Abutalib which is a
piece of land that he owned that was
between two mountains. It was a valley
and there they had they had a famine
for a number of years and in that place
and in that time Iban Abbas
was born and he quickly became one of
the leading scholars of of Islam amongst
the companions
for a number of reasons but most
notably the prophet sallall.aii
wasallam's specific dua for him. And so
we will continue with the remainder of
Iban Abbas's
summarized biography tomorrow
[Arabic recitation]
and then finish the narration
of
the
intentions and the way that Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala documents and counts
these intentions and their play with
respect to our actions.
[Arabic recitation]